أسوأ مخاوفي هي أننا نتسبب
بشكل كبير في مجال التكنولوجيا، حيث
تسبب الصناعة ضررًا كبيرًا للعالم
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أنه إذا سارت هذه التكنولوجيا بشكل خاطئ، فمن
الممكن أن تسوء تمامًا ونريد أن نكون
صريحين بشأن أننا نريد العمل مع
الحكومة لمنع حدوث ذلك
[موسيقى]
أعتقد أننا سنحتاج أيضًا إلى
قواعد وإرشادات حول ما هو
متوقع فيما يتعلق بالإفصاح من
شركة تقدم نموذجًا يمكن أن
يتمتع بهذا النوع من القدرات التي
تحدثت عنها لذا فأنا متوتر بشأن ذلك
[  الموسيقى]
إنها واحدة من المجالات التي تثير قلقي الأكبر،
حيث أن القدرة العامة
لهذه النماذج على التلاعب بالإقناع
لتقديم نوع من
المعلومات المضللة التفاعلية
الأجنبية
[الموسيقى]
نؤمن بها بشدة وندعو إليها
بالنسبة للتنظيم الدقيق للذكاء الاصطناعي
لسنوات حتى الآن، هذا ليس
موقفًا جديدًا، نعتقد أنه
يجب نشر التكنولوجيا
بطريقة مسؤولة وواضحة بشأن المخاطر